qui n'a pas craqué un jour sous la
pression ou sous la fatigue pour mon
invité se lasser produit un jour de
février 2020 dans l'hémicycle il en
parle aujourd'hui sans tabou et porte un
regard lucide sur ses débuts à
l'Assemblée
[Musique]
bonjour Nicolas turquois bonjour on vous
a confié un rôle important en 2020 sur
la première réforme des retraites vous
étiez qu'aux rapporteur de ce texte vous
étiez donc là pour le défendre face aux
députés dans l'hémicycle au début tout
s'est bien passé pour vous et puis au
fil du temps une partie de l'opposition
a joué la carte de l'obstruction les
séances entraînées en longueur la
tension est montée petit à petit jusqu'à
un moment fatidique qu'on va revivre en
images
citation qui m'est revenue tout à
l'heure je l'avais pas prévu certains
parmi vous ont déclaré la République
c'est moi et ben moi je vous dis que la
République c'est nous et vous vous êtes
rien
monsieur le ministre
alors cette séquence elle a beaucoup
tourné sur les réseaux sociaux à
l'époque mais pas seulement dans les JT
également qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ce
jour-là vous avez craqué oui on peut
dire ça comme ça vous êtes en fait quand
vous êtes rapporteur du texte et c'était
pas n'importe quel texte vous devez
répondre
vous devez argumenter à chaque
amendement de la majorité de
l'opposition vous devez argumenter
pourquoi vous ces données un avis
favorable ou défavorable en fonction de
ce qui s'est passé en commission
sachant que avant la séance de l'hémicy
qui a eu je crois deux semaines au moins
de commissions vous faites le même
travail avec des gens qui ont de plus
une spécialisation sur sur le sujet donc
s'accumule s'accumule de la fatigue
s'accumule de la tension
quand vous êtes à l'hémicycle vous
pouvez sortir aller prendre un café
comme vous êtes au banc vous devez en
permanence en train de défendre le texte
et là
de mémoire il y avait deux séries
d'amendements qui allaient se succéder
de 300 amendements chacune ou 400 enfin
j'ai plusieurs centaines qui proposaient
chacune de décaler l'âge d'application
de 6 mois des mesures des dates
d'application de 6 mois et donc
théoriquement aurait fallu que je
réponde à chacun de ces amendements en
disant pourquoi j'étais contre six mois
plus tard et six mois plus tard donc la
fatigue
plus ce côté extrêmement dur
physiquement et psychologiquement fait
qu'un moment donné de votre famille
pendant toute cette période là je crois
que même votre famille était présente ce
jour dans l'hémicycle et quelques deux
heures avant et venez me voir ce jour-là
parce que on n'avait pas vu depuis 15
jours ou trois semaines donc elle était
venue voir elle était plus présente
physiquement au moment où je dis ça mais
elle était présente deux heures avant et
je devais les retrouver à l'issue de
cette séance quand vous prononcez cette
phrase là vous vous dites quoi vous
dites oh là là j'ai commis une erreur
aussitôt vous savez vous dites aussitôt
j'ai fait j'ai j'ai fait j'ai fait j'ai
fait une erreur et puis vous je crois
que je m'excuse 5 minutes après voilà
mais c'est trop tard là c'est une forme
de burn out
je le je l'analyse pas spécifiquement il
y avait une très grande tension il y
avait il y avait un côté qui est très
dur physiquement il fait chaud les
oppositions étaient juste derrière moi
physiquement donc ça un effet c'est
c'est la goutte le supplice chinois la
goutte d'eau qui tombe en permanence en
soit une de plus se fait pas grand chose
mais l'accumulation fait qu'on explose
alors il y a eu cet épisode des
retraites mais c'est plus globalement un
peu tout le début de votre premier
mandat qui a été compliqué pour vous
vous ne vous en cachez pas vous avez eu
un peu de mal à trouver votre place à
prendre votre rôle alors j'ai eu du mal
à trouver ma place à l'hémicycle un
député il doit être sur le terrain dans
sa circonscription et ça c'est la même
chose que d'être un élu local sauf qu'il
faut faire du relationnel il faut aller
voir les gens faut répondre à leur et ça
ça se passait bien c'est la même chose
que d'être mère mais en version
XXL qui a été le problème dans
vous arrivez quand vous êtes élus député
avec l'image que vous faites d'un député
et l'image que vous faites d'un député
c'est celle du député qui était à
l'hémicycle alors il m'a fallu du temps
pour comprendre que le sujet il fallait
se spécialiser et ne pas intervenir
surtout puisque ça s'appelle une
discussion de comptoir et que le travail
principal était la Commission on se
spécialise on crée une relation avec
notamment le ou les ministres en charge
et là vous faites passer des idées mais
au début à l'hémicycle il y avait vous
avez un certain nombre de collègues qui
ont qui est peut-être plus de bagues
plus d'ambition plus de facilité mais à
quoi je sers dans cette poser cette
question concrètement
rétrospectivement c'est intéressant du
coup de réécouter la réaction que vous
avez eu le soir même de votre élection
en 2017 vous allez voir il y avait un
côté presque prémonitoire
je commence à comprendre ce qui ce qui
va se passer la révolution
quelle révolution
dans ma vie personnelle dans ma vie
professionnelle dans l'organisation du
quotidien les prochaines semaines en
tous les cas vont sûrement être avec
beaucoup de changements c'est vraiment
surprenant comme premier réaction parce
que d'habitude un député qui vient
d'être élu il est dans la joie vous vous
sent inquiet pourquoi mais
il y a eu plusieurs sujets mais
avant le premier enfin quand à l'issue
du premier tour je me suis dit c'est
possible que je sois élu je suis
agriculteur à la base vous embauchez pas
des gens au cas où vous seriez élus donc
de se dire comment ça va se passer
comment vous allez gérer votre
exploitation
je suis
une famille j'avais des enfants des
grands ados des ados et des grands ados
et de dire mais du jour au lendemain
je pars vers un monde nouveau et puis
cette découverte de la politique et
cette appréhension du côté dur de la
politique puisque on le voit des fois au
niveau local
je pense que j'ai vu assez tôt les défis
même si je les mesurais pas encore à ce
moment là dans dans leur ampleur mais
j'ai vu assez tôt que ça allait être
compliqué alors on va s'intéresser
justement à vos premiers pas dans la
politique c'est une émission on
s'intéresse un peu à ce qui peut
déclencher l'engagement d'un homme ou
d'une femme en politique et chez vous
quand on regarde un peu votre parcours
on voit que vous reprenez l'exploitation
agricole de vos parents en 2000 et qu'un
an plus tard vous êtes élu maire délégué
de votre petit village est-ce que les
deux sont liés il faut y avoir un alors
vous allez un peu vite en besoin un an
plus tard j'étais élu conseiller
municipal
mère délégué mais
je suis issu de la campagne donc revenir
à la campagne
n'était pas un problème pour moi mais
avec mon épouse nous sommes aussi
ingénieurs et elle est ingénieur
agronome elle était de la ville mais je
vais faire quoi dans ton ton ton projet
j'ai envie d'un métier qui correspond à
ma formation et je me suis dit que ce
village dans lequel j'avais toujours
vécu mais il était finalement assez
assez âgé par la population assez
sans produit et donc je me suis dit
qu'il fallait que je m'y investisse pour
que ma femme mes enfants ils trouvent
plein de satisfactions vous êtes
engageant politique pour votre famille
pour vos pour vos proches alors vous
avez donc été élu conseiller municipal
vous êtes ensuite devenu mer délégué de
votre village responsable départemental
du modem puis député aujourd'hui vous
consacrez l'essentiel de votre vie à la
politique mais vous avez toujours voulu
garder un pied dans votre exploitation
agricole pourquoi ah oui assurément
j'y suis toujours je suis toujours
agriculteur même si j'ai évidemment pris
de la distance j'ai participé aux
travaux l'été je suis la gestion au fur
et à mesure de l'année là on est en
train de voir avec des échases
c'était sûrement pour prendre de la
hauteur en matière politique non c'est
je fais des productions sous serre il
faut accrocher les cultures à hauteur
certaines cultures sous serre
et mais c'est quelque chose que j'aime
j'aime profondément il y a un risque de
se déconnecter un peu du terrain de la
réalité quotidienne des Français quand
on est élu c'est il faut garder un pied
dans le milieu professionnel c'est
d'abord parce que j'aime mon métier mais
je suis persuadé je le vois j'ai
l'impression de le voir avec eux avec
d'autres que on perd un contact avec une
certaine forme de réalité et d'avoir été
ou d'être n'est pas la même chose et là
sur les sujets agricoles d'être toujours
pleinement impliqué dans les sujets
agricoles me permet je pense d'avoir un
regard une expertise qui n'est pas la
même que si il y avait été il y a 5 ans
j'étais plus depuis 5 ans donc ça c'est
quelque chose auquel je tiens et puis et
puis vous reprenez pas un métier
d'agriculteur comme on pourrait
reprendre d'autres métiers ma fonction
députée peut s'arrêter plus brutalement
que je ne le savais et donc je suis une
forme de sécurité aussi une forme de
sécurité c'est l'heure de passer à notre
quiz alors je vais vous expliquer le
principe c'est assez simple je vais lire
le début d'une phrase et ce sera à vous
de la compléter c'est bon pour vous on y
va alors c'est parti sur les questions
d'agriculture justement on en parlait à
cet instant la plupart des députés Nico
ils y sont sensibles mais l'expertise
est assez faible elle est plutôt imagée
l'image d'une agriculture un petit peu
dépassée souvent et vous même où vous a
entendu un peu sur l'agriculture mais
vous en avez pas fait votre spécialité
c'est alors au tout début
j'étais vraiment sur les questions
agricoles et j'ai eu l'impression que
mes collègues me filaient tous les
sujets agricoles j'ai l'impression même
sur ce sujet là et en même temps si vous
connaissez bien le sujet c'est bien que
vous vous
j'ai envie de parler d'agriculture mais
je n'ai pas envie de faire que ça et le
sujet des retraites a été celui qui m'a
qui m'a tourné vers le champ social et
c'est un sujet que j'ai beaucoup j'ai
beaucoup apprécié donc agriculture mais
pas que
on poursuit à chaque fois que François
Ruffin prend la parole il m'énerve
lui en particulier ou cette façon de
s'opposer dans l'hémicycle c'était sa
façon de faire
changer il a changé François c'est il a
été vraiment vraiment très présent
pendant le débat des retraites et
parfois je peux comprendre qui vous est
un peu agacé parce que il allait
chercher la plus bête il cherchait à
vous faire ma sortie de route que vous
avez retransmis tout à l'heure quelques
mois plus tard il la rediffusé sur les
réseaux sociaux vous en avez voulu ah
oui oui parce que c'est pas que moi
c'est moi c'est ma famille c'est mes
collaborateurs et c'est des méthodes qui
sont inacceptables vous dites il a
changé
il a changé dans son expression et je
l'ai entendu l'autre jour même si il y
avait des arguments de fond que je ne
partageais pas je trouvais que la forme
pouvait amener à un échange un échange
il était peut-être moins possible avant
dernière phrase à l'Assemblée pour
survivre il faut
il faut s'investir dans des sujets
précis il faut gagner en expertise quand
on voit des il y a des parlementaires
qui ne sont pas de mon groupe ils
peuvent de mon groupe enfin de la
majorité ou pas mais qui ont une vraie
analyse approfondie des sujets vous avez
envie de les écouter il vous apporte
quelque chose un éclairage qui était
peut-être pas le vôtre mais qui vous
fait progresser et donc pour survivre il
faut être reconnu on l'a vu la phase
d'apprentissage a été parfois un peu
douloureuse pour vous dans votre premier
mandat de député vous n'êtes pas le seul
à avoir vécu cela est-ce que vous pensez
que ça pourrait être évité avec une
forme de formation pour les députés en
début de mandat ou est-ce que c'est à
chacun de se forger sa propre expérience
je crois alors en tous les cas au sein
de mon groupe le modem j'essaye avec
avec d'autres vis-à-vis des nouveaux
députés de leur donner des clés pour
qu'ils se sentent plus à l'aise parce
qu'il faut se protéger il faut se
protéger pour sa vie privée il faut se
protéger dans son rythme de travail et
c'est quand justement on arrive à se
protéger physiquement psychologiquement
qu'on va faire un bon député et je crois
que avoir une forme de bienveillance
avec nos nouveaux collègues permet
d'éviter en partie ce que j'ai pu
ressentir est-ce que beaucoup ressenti à
5 ans merci beaucoup Nicolas turquoise a
devenu dans la politique et moi merci à
vous
[Musique]